it's time for popcorn
all right sharon nicki you have been
selected quick
[Applause]
do you look so cute you coordinate with
drew and i
yeah all right come right over here
you are inspiring me
[Music]
all right if you correctly answer the
questions about today's show you'll win
1 000
and the good news is if you answer one
it's 100 and you answer two it's 200 you
know so if you could win something okay
all right i'm ready let's do it okay
first question jaleel white played urkel
on family matters what was his
catchphrase
did i do that and he had that very
famous catchphrase
did i do that
and we just wanted to hear
him question number two chef anne
burrell she had a go uh a phrase
misonplatz what language was it in
mm-hmm
uh-huh can i give you a hint can i give
her a hand
oh it sounds like french and mise en
place is a french term and it means put
in
[Music]
[Applause]
place and the final question is newsweek
recommends that you sleep in what for a
better night's sleep naked
next if you like to sleep naked as the
day you were born apparently the writers
at newsweek want you to
go for
[Applause]
thank
it
look at it
thank you so much
[Music]